[Música]
las semanas antes de una festividad
católica religiosa que genera muchas
preguntas en respecto a su significado y
también las tradiciones además del
contexto actual en el que se celebra la
también conocida como la semana mayor es
importante porque tiene como objetivo
recordar y celebrar el misterio de la
rendición de jesús el hijo de dios que
decide tomar lugar de nosotros y
sacrificarse por los pecados de la
humanidad esta época de importancia para
el cristianismo tiene como sus días
centrales jueves viernes santo y también
el domingo de resurrección el jueves la
iglesia católica conmemora la
institución de la eucaristía en la
última cena y el lavatorio de los pies
realizado por jesús según los evangelios
canónicos hoy viernes jesús fue
crucificado y sepultado y el domingo ese
es un día de celebración para los
practicantes católicos porque es cuando
se cree que jesús de nazaret resucita
entre los muertos para ello entonces
para entender más esta festividad
católica quiero saludar a en este
momento a álvaro ramis él es teólogo y
rector de la universidad academia de
humanismo cristiano gracias a álvaro por
estar con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 este fin de semana concluye
entonces un tiempo muy especial para
todos los católicos con la pascua porque
es una de las fiestas más importantes
para los creyentes y también en de qué
manera se celebra
bueno lo llamamos normalmente el triduo
pascual y contempla por lo tanto tres
días además del jueves santo que es la
conmemoración de la última cena pero el
trigo está compuesto por la muerte
sepultura y resurrección de jesucristo y
eso configura la festividad más
importante del cristianismo tenido a que
es el paso de la muerte a la vida del
anciano la redención que es la expiación
de los pecados para una vida nueva
liberada de la
tradición del peso de la culpa y por lo
tanto la resurrección no es solo la vida
eterna para aquellos que creen sino
también es la posibilidad de redimir
todas las culpas que la humanidad ha
acumulado en su victoria ahora álvaro le
pregunto si esto es una fiesta exclusiva
de los católicos porque a lo mejor en
otras ramas del cristianismo no la
celebran
bueno las celebran de distinta forma por
ejemplo el mundo ortodoxo tiene otra
fecha porque se rige por el calendario
lunar y por lo tanto hay un desfase en
el calendario pero se celebra muy
parecido en el caso del protestantismo
también se celebra porque está ligado
también al yom kipur es decir el
judaísmo celebra en esta misma fecha
una festividad muy parecida si
jesucristo por supuesto creo que también
tiene que ver con el recuerdo de los
pecados el peso de la culpa y su
liberación por parte de una nueva
posibilidad de vida entonces no solo en
ese sentido una fiesta cristiana sino
también que en este sentido es una
pascua y que una celebración que tiene
esas raíces hondas en el buda y claro
hablando de hoy específicamente viernes
santo tiene un gran significado
simbólico porque además tengo entendido
que es el único día del año donde no hay
mensaje en todo el mundo
claro no hay misa porque jesucristo no
está presente porque se conmemora su
muerte y la muerte no como algo
metafórico sino habrá muerte real una
muerte cruenta una muerte por tortura
una muerte que está liga a unas
condiciones materiales donde el imperio
romano impone la ley y cenó por medio
del proceso judicial muy muy poco
apegado el derecho nos condena a jesús
de nazaret a la muerte y por lo tanto es
una fiesta donde ese hecho lleva a la
reflexión sobre todos los dolores todas
las personas que hoy son también
ajusticiadas o son sometidas a torturas
son sometidas al escarnio son medianas
son sometidas a la violencia son las
víctimas las que tienen hoy día el
protagonismo hablábamos con nuestra
especialista en salud más romeros a la
de los ayunos justamente en esta pascua
hasta la pascua perdón no se consume
carnes los días viernes de dónde viene
esa costumbre y si hoy en día
y realmente
bueno muchas tradiciones
judías el islam incluso en el hinduismo
por ejemplo el budismo tienen prácticas
de ayuno que significa reducir la
ingesta de alimentos para purificar el
organismo pero sobre todo purificar la
mente el espíritu en un momento de
reflexión por medio de la conciencia
corporal eso normalmente debería ser la
atención durante un periodo de horas en
tiempo de cualquier alimento después se
fue cambiando y está finalizando y se
fue haciendo que pasáramos de no comer
nada a comer pescado en vez de carne por
ejemplo lo que la verdad no era el
sentido original de la práctica no lo es
para sustituir un alimento por otro sino
ser consciente corporalmente de una
ausencia para poder valorar el alimento
como un don de la vida ya para poder ser
consciente de la liberación digamos de
toxinas también para poder ser capaz de
auto dominarse el autocontrol del cuerpo
y de la voluntad eso también es parte
del ayuno claro porque en el catolicismo
digamos ese fue esta norma pues
debilitando y sustituyendo a lo mejor
bueno si ya quiere comer entonces
solamente como hemos pescado pero porque
a lo mejor en otras religiones como el
islam el judaísmo si se cumplen estos
ayunos y por qué no en el catolicismo
creo que el catolicismo no han logrado
comunicar bien el sentido de este tipo
de práctica y además porque la
espiritual hizo mucho fue tratando de
decir mire lo que se trata es de un
ayuno del alma el ayuno del alma
necesita cuerpo el cuerpo es el que
expresa esa necesidad el que se libera
por decirlo así de la pulsión
desde el hambre y ese autocontrol ha
hecho creo que en el catolicismo está
fallando una integración de lo corporal
y lo espiritual de una manera más
integral y eso muchas veces se encuentra
por ejemplo las religiones orientales
donde el cuerpo es mucho más central y
se expresa con mayor fuerza por ejemplo
en el yoga o en otras prácticas
espirituales donde lo corporal no se
disocia de
los rincones